in 1993 Steven Spielberg directed
Schindler's List the film he considers
the most important of his career the
movie shows his mastery of visual
imagery perhaps the most famous symbol
in this movie is the little girl in the
red coat wandering aimlessly during the
liquidation of the Krakow ghetto
Spielberg said she symbolizes how
obvious the Holocaust was yet nobody did
anything to stop it
it was always obvious as a little girl
wearing a red coat walking down the
street when he talks about the scene he
mentions the impact of having a color
show up in the middle of a
black-and-white movie but he doesn't
mention the color itself which begs the
question why does red work so well in
the scene if all that matters is having
color show up in black and white the
symbolism would be the same if her coat
was blue but blue drastically changes
the feeling of the scene as would any
other color each color is packed with
its own symbolism filmmakers may not
know all the nuances of a colors history
and meaning but they understand each
colors emotional payoff
so what symbolism is unique to the color
red why do some filmmakers make such
pointed careful use of red the color
definitely has a very unusual biological
effect on humans it evokes all sorts of
passionate emotions when we feel angry
embarrassed or flirtatious we literally
get red in the face if to boxers of
equal skill fight each other the one in
red is actually more likely to win
several studies suggest that it's the
color people look most attractive
wearing there's even an urban legend
that red cars are more likely to get
pulled over red stands out amongst other
colors and filmmakers have always
understood this phenomenon the
screenwriters of The Wizard of Oz wanted
to show off the beauty of Technicolor so
they had to change the plain silver
slippers from the novel the sought-after
and powerful slippers did not become
emeralds green or bright yellow one
color suited them best if something is
important red gets the job done on its
own we use the color red to indicate
anything in the real world that has been
tainted by the other
and red is used specifically to connote
really explosively emotional moments in
situations it's no surprise that red is
mankind's original color not only was it
the first color used in art in cave
paintings but nearly every Western
language has a name for it before any
other color before Newton's rainbow
early philosophers put red in the middle
of the color spectrum directly in
between black and white so it's no
surprise that many filmmakers have an
instinct to place black white and red
together it seems like reducing the
color spectrum exponentially enhances
the symbolic weight of these three
colors Snow White the Evil Queen dressed
in black the red Apple but I think to
really get at the meaning of such a
unique and important color and why a
scene like in Schindler's List would use
it we have to look at its historical
significance the perception of color is
not just a biological phenomenon but a
cultural one and it's symbolic power
comes from two objects fire and blood
two elements always associated with red
and universally encountered by every
society throughout history even today
whenever a dictionary defines red they
typically use fire and blood in their
explanation the relationship between red
and blood makes sense since all living
vertebrates have red blood but the
association of red with fire is less
clear after all fire isn't exactly red
but more of an orange or yellow why do
we culturally linked red with the color
of fire historians argue it's because
many Asian societies saw fire as a
living being its domestication was the
symbolic birth of civilization and like
the Sun it is a source of life by
providing light and heat blood and fire
were always at the center of early
religious traditions animal blood
sacrifices were thought to lead to good
harvests and many beliefs fire was
passed down from the gods
like when Prometheus stole it in Greek
mythology a key component of these two
elements is their symbolism of both life
and death on one hand fire keeps you
warm protects you from predators and
lights up your home but once it's out of
control fire leads to death and
destruction
similarly blood is a source of human
life but the sight of blood indicates
injury and too much means death
Christian stories clearly reflect our
ancient contradictory relationships with
fire and blood on one hand God uses fire
to communicate with Moses through a
burning bush but fire also symbolizes
the eater
tormenting of hell explaining why hell
is always red what does represent Jesus
is gruesome crucifixion but Cardinals
re-appropriated that meaning into
something positive by wearing red as a
symbol of Jesus's blood sacrifice red
symbolism varies wildly depending on the
time and place but it always ties back
to these core elements red is a symbol
of love and passion but it also became a
symbol of prostitution and illicit sex
in the Middle Ages showing the pitfalls
of too much passion of getting too close
to the flame so to speak red was the
symbol of the French Revolution and from
then on the color became a sign of
extreme political upheaval oftentimes
violent always passionate aggressive and
filled with life the point is if a
critic looks at red through the lens of
its origins in fire and blood then the
symbolic power of red becomes much more
obvious many movies use red to tap into
these powerful historical roots red is
heat it is a symbol of life and light in
an otherwise desolate and cold world it
adorns energetic youthful characters Wes
Anderson loves it because it injects
visual life into his scenes Rhetta often
sexualizes female characters echoing its
association with love and lust but
sometimes red goes too far are you
listening to me neo were you looking at
the woman in the red dress
I was again
[Music]
as much as red indicates life it just as
easily signals death and horror what was
ones passion becomes obsession to the
point of self-destruction no color
better captures youth and sexuality and
the boys of a Clockwork Orange represent
this sexuality to a dangerous extreme
sometimes a red car is just an easy way
to indicate speed but it sometimes goes
deeper than that Cameron's dad loves his
red car to the extreme more so than even
his own son the car and boys in the hood
is a looming sign of death that appears
out of nowhere the idea that there is no
escape for these characters gets
reinforced in the opening shot an
example of red as the colour of warning
and danger movies also channeled their
religious significance of the color in
Mean Streets Charlie holds his hand over
flames in a form of personal penance a
nod to his fear of the flames of hell
it's no coincidence that Tony's bar is
bathed too in red an indication that the
place contains sex blood and violence a
world Charlie wants to escape perhaps
the most powerful use of red is when
filmmakers can juxtapose its positive
and negative symbolism showing the two
kinds of red side by side the ending of
don't look now has a bizarre montage
revealing the true identity of the girl
in the red coat part of the horror of
the finale is the contrast of different
classic red images the youthful coat
followed by his blood then sex and even
flames in a church all these images
mixed together disorients the viewer
through the unusual pairings of red
Schindler's List perfectly embodies all
the symbolic uses of red its origins in
fire and blood the religious
significance developed from pagan
rituals all the way to Christianity and
the harnessing of the colors dual
meanings the movie begins with the
lighting of a flame as a Jewish family
celebrates the Sabbath color fades away
when the fire goes out and the story
descends into Cracow Poland during World
War two right from the beginning the
film establishes fire as a symbol of
Jewish tradition and to the
extinguishing of the flame for shadows
the end of Jewish life in Poland the
recurring flames throughout the movie
symbolize both danger and life in one
scene spielberg superimposes a burning
flame onto oscar schindler's chest to
symbolize his gradual transformation
from a greedy businessman to a
benevolent savior the flames of his
factory are a source of life as he saves
Jewish people from extermination in
contrast to the flames
the Prashad labor camp burned bright and
harsh in the foreground as the Nazis
walk into the factory in the background
a reminder of the death and destruction
they bring with them at their most
extreme flames are associated with
horrific mass graves
but when Schindler invites his Jewish
workers to practice the Sabbath the
flames become color once again in
Schindler's Factory the Jewish tradition
can continue he provides light in a
world surrounded by darkness
flames are at the same time a symbol of
the Jewish people surviving and a symbol
of their destruction in this movie blood
and death also go hand in hand with
numerous executions and murders but one
scene uses blood in a more subtle but
equally disturbing way when the Nazis
want to separate the healthy from the
sick a group of women in the camp apply
their own blood as makeup they're using
blood to try to appear more alive it's
such a cruel irony that they have to
bleed to look more lively so they can in
turn avoid a bloody death self-harm is a
form of self-preservation in comparison
to the rest of the movie this moment may
seem benign but it perfectly captures
the absurdity of the Holocaust how life
and death were so disturbingly
intertwined blood is death and life all
at once the red coat is an incredible
summation of all these ideas on one hand
the little girl is youth life and
innocence the red calls attention to her
fiery warmth and young blood but once
she hides under the bed her red coat
loses its colour and we see it later in
a whole new deadly context the code is
now presumably red with blood to be
disposed of in flames Schindler's List
and the girl in the coat are the story
of the color red they are a story of
death and life coexisting together the
red of Oskar Shindler is the red of life
surrounded by his red is the red of the
Holocaust
the list is life
around its margins my stack up not every
instance of the color is as Extreme as
Schindler's List but an overt uses of
read the same symbolic principles apply
it has a powerful and primal response
for the viewer coming from the human
understanding of blood and fire
filmmakers don't necessarily have
knowledge of the actual symbolic history
of different colors but the best ones
definitely know how to use it long
before directing artists understood the
strengths of different colors if a
Calvinist painter wanted to give
prominence to someone in their painting
all they had to do was add a red sash
any artist can benefit from knowing the
various strengths and weaknesses of each
color Olympia's annually is an
incredible graphic designer who
harnesses bold colors in her
illustrations if you want to learn the
secrets of using color in your graphic
design you can sign up for her class on
Skillshare Skillshare has over 20,000
classes on a ton of topics from design
to business the first 500 people to
click on the link in the description
will get two months of completely free
access to skill share that's the graphic
design class plus thousands of others
from marketing and video editing to
photography thanks for watching and a
big THANK YOU to Skillshare for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
you